[Musique]
nouvelle édition du café politique
aujourd'hui avec yves vandewalle bonjour
bonjour et bienvenue à montigny le
bretonneux au cours du prochain quart
d'heure nous allons parler de votre
parcours de vos engagements pour nous
habituer le cadre a un peu changé mais
le formule de l'émission de elle ne
change pas nous allons parler de vous
vous êtes conseiller départemental des
yvelines mais aussi président du parc
naturel de la haute vallée de chevreuse
un département que vous connaissez bien
si vous êtes mais alors je reprends vous
me corriger si je me trompe en allemagne
vous avez grandi à versailles c'est bien
ça oui oui oui je suis né c'est de
circonstance de la prière qui font que
je suis en allemagne vous père était
militaire c'est aussi simple que ça mais
en réalité depuis 1951 je suis à
versailles enfin vous connaissez bien
vous est implanté dans ce département
vous êtes resté vous êtes vous étiez
professeur agrégé de géographie a
travaillé chez j'ai enseigné aux et j'ai
été professeur à trappes pendant onze
années au lycée de la place de dauphin
on a créé un peu au milieu des champs de
patates avait à l'époque oui c'était un
quartier tout neuf en plein essor et
j'ai été j'ai fini ma carrière
d'enseignant stricto sensu au lycée
hoche où j'avais été là auparavant et
avant j'avais été à sa jambe et une ola
vous n'aviez pas une vocation une envie
de vous lancer dans la politique dès le
début en fait il y avait ces voyages
professionnels en servant tout pas du
tout en réalité je suis arrivé tout à
fait par hasard
en 1977 on est venu frapper à ma porte
et on m'a demandé si je voulais bien me
présenter sur une liste aux municipales
comme c'est souvent le cas d'ailleurs
dans des petits villages
j'ai dit oui sans trop savoir ce à quoi
je m'engageais et voilages et après
c'est un engrenage on se prend au jeu et
qu'est ce qui vous a plu qu'est ce qui
vous a séduit
quand il est plus aimé l'expérience
ce pas toujours facile c'est pas
toujours facile mais c'est en même temps
une forme d'accomplissement moi j ai
toujours trouvé deux grands centres
d'intérêts le premier centre d'intérêt
c'est que c'est une expérience le mot va
sembler prétentieux balzacienne vous
découvrez la société dans la mesure où
c'est une occasion de contact
extraordinaire quand vous occuper les
fonctions de maire vous êtes au
carrefour de tout ce qui se passe dans
la commune
ça c'est le premier intérêt le deuxième
intérêt c'est que c'est une des rares
fonction où vous pouvez avoir une idée
et l'amener jusqu'à sa réalisation
j'ai eu la chance de croiser des gens
qui m'ont fait confiance je pense un
ancien maire du mesnil guy le fémur que
je respectais beaucoup
franck borotra qui a joué un rôle
important
valérie pécresse dont vous étiez le
suppléant et qui une fois le
gouvernement vous l'avez en cela c'est
arrivé en 2002
franck borotra m'avait demandé si
j'acceptais d'être le suppléant de mme
pécresse pour l'aider à s'implanter et
est entre guillemets parachute et donc
je les fais avec beaucoup de plaisir je
n'ai jamais regretté ce choix je crois
qu'on a fait un très beau parcours et
avec vale pécresse je crois qu'on
partage cette même sensibilité qui est
seul on va dire d'un gaullisme social
c'est à dire un mélange
de libéralisme économique qui est un
gage d'efficacité mais en même temps
avec une sensibilité sociale parce qu'il
faut assurer la cohésion de la nation
il ya beaucoup de petits trouver sa
place par don et non ses moi il ya
beaucoup de remises en cause au sein des
républicains aujourd'hui vous parler de
la ligne politique justement vous vous y
retrouvez aux républicains aujourd'hui
la ligne de laurent wauquiez par exemple
j'avoue que la ligne de le révoquer
n'est pas ma tasse de thé je ne sais pas
si c'est lui qui ira aux prochaines
élections j'espère que
d'ici là les choses ont changé donc je
trouve
je trouve que les premières prestations
de leurs gros qui ne sont pas à la
hauteur des enjeux du pays qu'est-ce qui
vous déçoit ses prises de position ses
discours
ce qu'on a pu lui reprocher aussi en off
les petites phrases qui ont été écrites
et puis je dois dire que oui j'avoue que
j'apprécie peu sais c'est pas la mesurer
à la hauteur des enjeux du pays
voilà quand on ambitionne et je suppose
que son ambition c'est d'être un jour
président de la république
je pense que il faut se placer à la
bonne hauteur c'est à dire que ce parti
des républicains vous pourriez quitter
la question ne se pose pas dans ces
termes
en fait comme je vous le dis je n'ai
jamais été encarté jusqu'en 2007 où
valérie pécresse m'a dit qu'il était
quand même difficile d'être à
l'assemblée nationale sans quand même
prendre une carte de parti politique ce
que je les fais comme je suis la nièce
prix libre je les fais un petit peu
contre un mais je les fais cela dit je
n'ai rien renier et j'ai toujours
respecté mes engagements
les républicains restent sur une ligne
qui vise effectivement à favoriser le
développement économique du pays avec
une certaine protection sociale moi je
le soutiendrai mais aujourd'hui je ne
vois pas suffisamment clair en réalité
pour soutenir les républicains faudrait
d'abord qu'il ya un projet des
républicains mais je pense aussi que
nous devons veiller à respecter aussi
je tirais ce qui est dans notre adn je
suis de ceux qui pensent que dans les
yvelines
le fait d'avoir augmenter massivement
les impôts comme nous l'avons fait au
conseil départemental 2016 n'a pas été
sans effet comment voulez vous que nos
électeurs auxquels on explique qu'il
faut pas augmenter les impôts qu'il faut
la modération fiscale s'ils retrouvent
quand ceux qui sont au pouvoir et qui se
réclament de ces idées font le contraire
on a parlé de votre expérience en tant
que rapidement en tant que maire de
lévis annonce était encore en 89 pendant
dix ans où on a expliqué aussi que vous
aviez à travailler avec valérie pécresse
au sein de l'assemblée nationale et puis
entre les lignes on a bien compris votre
implication au sein du conseil
départemental votre arrivée c'était en
wissant du conseil général à l'époque il
n'y a pas de lassitude dans cet
engagement au sein du département dont
je me suis fait non parce que j'ai eu la
chance
dit être à des moments particulièrement
favorable j ai été notamment
avec franck borotra j'ai eu beaucoup
beaucoup de plaisir à travailler avec
lui est un grand république arrêt pour
lequel j'avais beaucoup de respect ce
qui n'interdit pas d'ailleurs une
certaine énergie mais il maniait ça avec
beaucoup de subtilité de finesse et avec
un achemine j'ai eu la chance d'être
responsable du développement économique
et du numérique sur le département
j'avoue que ça a été une période tout à
fait exaltante parce que ça m'a permis
de lancer d'initié de grands projets
n'ont pas seul évidemment partenariat
comme tous les grands projets et
aujourd'hui j'avoue que lorsque je passe
chez bd comme et que je sais la part que
j'ai eu la chance de pouvoir y prendre
dans ce projet avec notamment des
grandes entreprises comme renault et
peugeot ou bien à l'université de saint
quentin
je me dis que c'est une très belle
réalisation et au sein du département
aujourd'hui vous y êtes à l'aise je vous
pose la question parce qu'on parle de
votre regard sur le travail de laurent
wauquiez mais sur le travail de pierre
bédier notamment parce que vous vous
opposez souvent aux décisions vous
parliez de cette hausse des impôts qui
n'était pas là la bienvenue il ya votre
rejet aussi de ce projet de
rapprochement avec les hauts-de-seine
voire de fusion avec les hauts-de-seine
quelle est votre position par exemple
sur sur le choix de pierre bédier de
briguer la présidence des républicains
dans le département bah écoutez
nous avons deux sujets n'y en ce qui
concerne le département des yvelines
moi j'ai un mandat ce sera d'ailleurs
mon dernier mandat sera clair j'ai un
mandat de mes électeurs et moi je
défends les idées pour lesquelles j'ai
été élu donc je dois voter à peu près 95
% des délibérations parce que beaucoup
ne pose pas de problème mais j'ai des
désaccords effectivement que pierre
bédier
le problème c'est que parfois des gens
ne se fût ce que pas d'avoir des
opposants puis un bédié a beaucoup de
mal à supporter qu'on ne soit pas
d'accord avec voilà c'est comme ça donc
ça a tendance à radicaliser les choses
comme je suis pas par nature très
radicale loin de là effectivement on a
dancefloor je veux dire quand on
augmente les impôts de 65%
je trouve que c'est une aberration face
est contraire à l'adn de la droite
enfin on peut pas à la fois tenir un
discours national et faire le contraire
le calme
c'est impossible après on est totalement
décrédibilisé et après il faut pas
s'étonner des résultats qu'on aille aux
élections
la fusion 78,92 on est quand même dans
une fantastique supercherie je tire ça
ne rime à rien ça n'a aucun sens les
yvelines sont un département très
différent des hauts de seine
nous sommes un des départements les plus
riches de france on n'a aucune besoin
d'une béquille
alors qu'elle était on ne sait toujours
pas d'ailleurs quel est l'objectif de
cette fusion on nous a dit que c'était
pour faire des économies
lui très bien ta mutualiser un peu les
moyens oui bah le dernier budget a
montré qu'on avait réalisé strictement
aucune économie en fait en mutualisant
les services à ce stade
et aujourd'hui on fait peur à tout le
monde vous avez une campagne bien de
l'avoir encore il ya des affiches énorme
tout près d'ici
pour dire le département est menacée le
département des yvelines n'est pas
menacé du tout il faut sauver
département avait sauvé de quoi le
président du conseil départemental a
rencontré le président de la république
qui lui a dit que les départements de la
grande couronne ne serait ne seraient
pas touchés donc à quoi ce à quoi rime
cette campagne je ne comprends pas sauf
peut-être à sauver le 92 est ce que
c'est vraiment la sphère des yvelines
donc ça c'est pour le fonds pour les
choix qui sont faits et ensuite sur la
personne qui brigue aujourd'hui la
présidence du département
écoutez je pense que il faut il faut il
est en pha les dernières élections de
l'an suffisamment montré il faut qu'une
nouvelle génération arrive aux affaires
on a besoin de gens qui rassemble aussi
clairement il ya une vraie dynamique
macro qu'on soit d'accord ou pas il ya
une vraie dynamique autour d'emmanuel
macro est donc l'enjeu ce sont les
prochaines élections
la question c'est de savoir comment on
peut les gagner je pense que pour les
gagner c'est un schéma extrêmement
classique il faut rassembler il faut
donc un profil rassembleur
pierre bédier est un meneur d'hommes
c'est un c'est quelqu'un qui a une
énergie extraordinaire mais je ne suis
pas sûr qu'il ait le profil de
rassembleur qui conviennent on l'a vu
tout récemment je veux dire la façon
dont ils gèrent le département provoque
plutôt décision des conflits et des
divisions
un dernier mot pour conclure cette
émission un poste dont on n'a pas parlé
c'est celui de président du parc naturel
régional de la haute vallée de chevreuse
et un poste qui vous permet aussi de
défendre au sein du département
cet espace de le préserver le
rapprochement aujourd'hui par exemple
avec aussi saint-quentin-en-yvelines de
certaines communes des discussion qui
s'engage
vous pensez que ça va dans le bon sens
ou est-ce qu'il faut préserver un petit
peu défendre les intérêts uniquement du
pnr et et garder ses frontières a pas du
tout je trouve au contraire que l'on a
réussi à bâtir en une trentaine d'années
un équilibre qui est tout à fait
remarquable
sur notre territoire en jouant d'une
complémentarité entre d'un côté la ville
nouvelle de saint quentin en fallait que
ce binôme 50 à 50 ans divise toujours
maintenant et le parc naturel régional
nos territoires sont complémentaires
on ne dit pas assez mais les gens qui
vivent en vallée de chevreuse sont les
gens sont les salariés qui en même temps
travailler font vivre saint quentin en
yvelines et essai de cet équilibre qui
permet à la fois de garantir de l'emploi
mais aussi une certaine qualité de vie
c'est ça qui fait la richesse de notre
territoire et donc je me garderai bien
d'opposer les deux confrontés nous avons
deux territoires complémentaire est une
des questions que je me pose vous
parliez des manuel da cruz m'interroge
sur la loi est lent et je j'aimerais
bien que cette loi ne supprime pas
certaines dispositions qui sont
essentielles en matière d'urbanisme pour
le parc-nature la jeune à ce parc
naturel vous y tenez particulièrement
c'est ça fait partie de notre adn aussi
oui il se trouve que j'ai fait des
études de géographie cheveux gris
géographie et j'ai fait ma maîtrise sur
la forêt dans le massif du vercors boxe
c'est pendant le mandat mode
j'ai toujours conservé cette sensibilité
environnementale
je crois que c'est très fort c'est une
de mes grandes déceptions conseil
départemental c'est que nous n'avons
strictement aucune politique en matière
d'environnement et d'écologie
je le regrette profondément parce quand
je vois à quel vitesse vont les choses
en province avec vale pécresse on vient
de signer un nouveau contrat de parc
à une garantie des moyens assez
importants notamment pour avancer sur
des sujets comme la mobilité durable ou
sur les énergies renouvelables parce que
en ile de france on est très en retard
par mois la province et j'espère que
l'on va pouvoir bâtir de beaux projets
en tout cas les équipes du parc qui
travaille en ce moment
merci beaucoup ils vendent mal s'est
déversée participer à ce qu'a fait plus
c'est moi qui vous remercie de m'avoir
fait profiter de ce fait découvrir
d'ailleurs de ce très beau cadre merci
merci m
[Musique]
oui
et